la majorité des réfugiés dans le monde
est invisible
ils sont invisibles d'abord parce que
contrairement à ce qu'on pense souvent
la plupart des réfugiés ne vivent pas en
europe quand on regarde les chiffres on
se rend compte que 86% des réfugiés à
l'heure actuelle vivent dans les pays du
sud
très souvent dans des pays proches des
zones de conflit ils sont invisibles
aussi parce que la plupart d'entre eux
ne trouvent pas refuge dans les camps
humanitaires de ces pays mais bien plus
dans les villes est donc loin de
l'assistance humanitaire est loin de
l'attention médiatique
à chaque nouvelle crise de réfugiés on
voit à la télévision ces images de caen
ces tentes qui abritent des enfants des
femmes des hommes des vieillards
et pourtant ces images elles ne
reflètent que très partiellement la
réalité des déplacements de populations
à l'heure actuelle quand on regarde les
chiffres une fois de plus on se rend
compte que 58% des réfugiés aujourd'hui
vivent dans les villes et non dans les
camps humanitaires
en fait quand on y regarde de près c'est
pas aussi surprenant que ça pourrait le
paraître à première vue il faut bien
s'imaginer penser à l'âge que vous avez
à l'heure actuelle et rajoutez-y 17 ans
17 ans c'est le temps moyen que les
réfugiés passent en exil
donc il faut s'imaginer soi-même vivre
pendant 17 ans dans un camp donc sous
une tente sans accès à une éducation
digne de ce nom sans accès au marché du
travail dans une très grande précarité
dépendants de l'aide humanitaire pour sa
propre survie celle de vos proches
est ce que vous vous resteriez 17 ans
dans un camp de réfugiés
ce qui est certain c'est que la plupart
des réfugiés à l'heure actuelle ils
préfèrent plutôt aller dans les villes
avec cet espoir de reconstruire leur vie
de retrouver un semblant de normalité
le problème c'est que la plupart du
temps dans les pays du sud
ça veut dire vivre dans une très grande
précarité avec très peu de soutien
humanitaire ou pas de soutien
humanitaire du tout dans une situation
des plus complexes et en somme dans la
plus grande visibilité
or on ne peut pas aider ceux qu'on ne
voit pas la première manière de résoudre
un problème c'est avant tout le voir et
j'ai donc confondez urban réfugiés en
2012 avec david del valle avec cette
idée toute simple rendre visibles les
invisibles attirer l'attention
l'assistance humanitaire sur ces
millions de réfugiés urbains dans les
pays du sud alors à urban refugees on a
défini trois leviers d'action le premier
c'est le plaidoyer politique ça veut
dire attirer l'attention des décideurs
politiques l'attention de la communauté
internationale sur la nécessité de
prendre en charge les réfugiés urbains
mais aussi sur la nécessité de
développer des alternatives aux camps de
réfugiés
parce que les camps ne peuvent pas être
une réponse systématique aux crises
concrètement ça veut dire qu'on milite
on rencontre des décideurs politiques on
siège dans un groupe de travail des
nations unies et c'est un travail
évidemment de longue haleine mais c'est
essentiel si on veut que les choses
changent à grande échelle si évidemment
l'aspect politique a toute son
importance
il est aussi essentiel d'aider les ong
la communauté humanitaire a développé
des programmes pour les réfugiés urbains
et c'est là notre deuxième levier
d'action faut bien comprendre que ça
fait 50 ans que les camps humanitaires
sur la manière privilégiée de gérer les
crises de réfugiés mais comme on s'en
doute aller soutenir des réfugiés dans
des villes ça requiert une expertise qui
est complètement différente
il va falloir par exemple aller négocier
avec les autorités municipales
il va falloir identifier les réfugiés
dans des zones urbaines très vaste il
faut aussi parvenir à les soutenir sans
créer des tensions avec la population
locale qui est déjà très souvent
précarisés par la crise donc là il ya un
véritable phénomène de un véritable défi
d'adaptation à l'heure actuelle pour
l'airé pour les pour les pour la
communauté humanitaire pour les ong et
pour répondre à ce défi l'adaptation
on a créé donc un réseau d'entr'aide un
réseau de partage de bonnes pratiques
entre les ong
donc en clair à l'heure actuelle nous
avons un réseau de 80 ong dans 40 pays
qui s'entraident à développer a répliqué
des programmes pour les réfugiés urbains
qui marche
pour vous donner un exemple à l'heure
actuelle on est en train d'aider une ong
en jordanie a développé un centre
communautaire pour les réfugiés urbains
en la mettant en lien avec une ong en
indonésie qui a une très forte expertise
dans ce domaine
mais si évidemment les politiques et les
humanitaires ont leur rôle à jouer
eh ben le plus essentiel en tout cas à
nos yeux est le plus efficace
ça reste encore de soutenir les
initiatives des réfugiés urbains eux
mêmes ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est qu'un peu partout dans le monde
les réfugiés créer des groupes d'entre
aide pour soutenir leur propre
communauté
c'est un peu comme si tous ici nous
étions déplacés demain qu'on devenait
réfugiés qu'on allait trouver refuge au
maroc
une des premières choses qu'on ferait ce
serait de s'entraider entre français
on créerait sans aucun doute un groupe
d'entre elles le groupe d'entre elles
des réfugiés français au maroc les
réfugiés urbains font ça un peu partout
dans le monde et j'ai pu voir de mes
propres yeux
l'efficacité de ces groupes d'entre aide
quand je travaillais au moyen-orient
avant de créer urban réfugiés
l'organisation avec laquelle je
travaillais avait été mis au courant de
la détention d'omar réfugiés soudanais
grâce au groupe dans traite de réfugiés
soudanais du pays qui nous avait alerté
sur sa disparition
c'est donc des groupes qui jouent un
rôle essentiel
mais le problème c'est que ces groupes
sont très souvent informel leurs
compétences leurs moyens sont très
limités et donc pour remédier à ce
problème là on a créé un programme
d'incubation
c'est un programme de six mois où nous
offrons des formations de manière
intensive au leader réfugiés de ces
organisations pour qu'ils puissent faire
de leur organisation d'aidé d une
organisation solide et donc de la même
manière que les entreprises ont mckinsey
les réfugiés urbains on human réfugiés
et notre incubateur on utilise les mêmes
méthodologique ces cabinets de conseil
pour ceux qui sont familiers du jargon
on fait de la conduite du changement de
l'audit des pratiques et donc on n'aide
ces groupes d'entre aide à mieux se
structurer
à l'heure actuelle on travaille avec un
groupe de réfugiés afghans dans un pays
d'asie du sud-est et à l'issue de notre
programme
cette organisation pourra véritablement
délivrer des services de qualité à sa
propre communauté
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'ils
pourront appeler les nations unies quand
un de leurs membres sera mis en
détention
ça veut dire qu'ils pourront faire des
classes pour les enfants qui n'ont pas
accès au système éducatif qui pourront
faire des sessions d'accès aux soins
parce que les réfugiés n'ont pas accès
aux systèmes de santé dans le pays dans
lequel ils sont ça veut dire qu'ils
pourront également faire du plaidoyer
pour leurs propres droits notamment
auprès des nations unies
y a un grand rêve en fait derrière ce
projet là et c'est celui de créer un
conseil international des réfugiés
ce sera en quelque sorte une fédération
de tous ces groupes dans très de
réfugiés au niveau international qui
fera porter tous ensemble leur voix je
vous ai dit qu'à urban refugees on avait
trois leviers d'action en vérité on en a
un quatrième est ce quatrième levier
c'est vous sans vous ces groupes
ces réfugiés ils resteront dans l'oubli
vous pouvez dès aujourd'hui vous engagez
av
des associations comme les nôtres on a
des besoins de compétences on a des
besoins de bénévoles vous pouvez changer
la donne et on n'y arrivera pas sans
vous chaque jour de nouveaux réfugiés
partent vers les villes et donc vers
l'oubli
il est grand temps de rendre visible
l'invisible
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]